I hate this hair I'll be honest with you
women don't like guys that look safe as
[ __ ] yeah I look dangerous as [ __ ]
chuckling what's your man who like this
hair girl what's up look like I got a
job and a stable lifestyle Oh what is
going off a little too caca
mmm now when it comes to dieting dieting
is a finicky thing and what I mean by
that
I [ __ ] hey listen you already know if
I can the genie my first wish would
always be about food I would wish that
bad food was good for you and good food
was bad for you because that would only
make sense you know I just don't get it
if the food tastes good shouldn't it be
good for you it doesn't make any sense
you know what mother nature you done
[ __ ] up and yes I know there's a gun
on you out there they want to make a
life lesson about everything
damn it it's like that so you appreciate
that good things are hard to come by
what's wrong with you why would you say
that to an angry hungry bet man you
trying to get killed cut skinny people
always got things twisted to let all you
know what I'm skinny so I bet you I can
run faster than you know watch you ever
check your legs on all fours like a
goddamn cheetah I just chase you down
that's right you just wait till we get
caught in a snowstorm you think that
because I'm fat y'all go eat me because
I got the most meat on me [ __ ] you got
it twisted before you even think about
using me I already ate happy family
here's the thing I know a lot of you
guys out there want to know my diet or
something like that but I'm gonna tell
you something right now when it comes to
dining there are so many different ways
to go about it but as an unhealthy
fatness something that I've always had
trouble with was portion control and if
you're anything like me when you eat
something really good that's definitely
a demon that you had to fight on the
regular you know for me growing up I was
always told to clean my plate no matter
what it didn't matter if you were full
or if you were about to explode you just
had to get it clean and that were the
rules well guess what you're an adult
now and when you're full did you know
that you can stop until my friend told
me now when he stops being hungry he
stopped eating that's crazy right what
that's not just me whatever for me I'm
to realize that everything in moderation
is key for me you've got to be able to
control how much you eat and exactly
what you're eating before really looking
into changing my eating habits the
calories and the stuff that was going
inside my body was pretty ridiculous
you know what's funny you know you're
fat when you start any healthy
properties to the foods that you know
you're not supposed to eat steak uh
cerebral flavored butter is calcium
fortified will be good gummy bears you
know red and you know what there's a
small amount of you out there that have
it leave this stupid common such as it
is only about calorie in and calorie out
go [ __ ] your yeah it might personally be
my fault because my personal journey
with this is actually kind of weight
loss because I am alright however I am
NOT promoting weight loss per se I am
promoting a healthier lifestyle so I
don't know how many times I could tell
you about this but these uploads are not
about losing weight it's about getting
healthy so shut da [ __ ] and once again
triple FF I want you guys to think about
this this channel is not here to tell
you how to lose your weight it is here
to motivate and get your ass moving so
you guys can find the knowledge for
yourself and be active about what you
want in life what I'm doing right now is
researching and learning from a lot of
other people to see what works for me
we are all not to say what I'm doing
will not necessarily work for you
remember that what's the whole point of
being thin if you're not healthy so
triple F M if you don't know about
nutrition at certain dice be active go
out there and learn it and don't listen
to people who don't know what the [ __ ]
they're talking about they're dumb asses
well anyways fam I am out and remember
life is always what you make it but it's
up to you to take what you deserve let's
go for broke what is going on you do but
I know
cause some of you [ __ ] out
there so stop leaving those [ __ ]
comments I don't want to personally
block you because I feel like you aren't
trying to help but you just stupid as
[ __ ] but stop being [ __ ] stupid stop
leaving advice when you don't know what
the [ __ ] you're talking about
state your credentials show your [ __ ]
pictures all showing videos of you doing
what the [ __ ] you're doing if not shut
the [ __ ] up I don't want you like to
influence these kids who don't know what
the [ __ ] they're doing be quiet be quiet
but once again these videos are brought
to you by go for broke apparel you don't
think yeah I like this hot biscuits
heart [ __ ] going on here I actually love
this show so what am i favorites in a
minute I know a lot of you guys top some
of the gear and some of you guys were
asking about the 3/4 head meaty yeah
there was only three of those bins so if
you could not cop it I'm sorry you can't
convince gone ever those of you who did
get it you guys know the quality on that
[ __ ] what a bomb bigger there so yes
more spring designs coming out in a
couple of weeks be ready for that and of
course you know I'm gonna put that [ __ ]
on sale for you again because I love
your like that I love your liked it I've
been doing some weird ass [ __ ] lately I
don't know but anyway couple that BAM I
will see you all next time and remember
there is going to be a Sunday upload and
I promise you will be on time this time
because I just got a little busy passing
hair Oh place we learned David is like
that because oh why is it like that
David but I started to realize that I
couldn't have certain few feuds when I
couldn't when I couldn't have certain
feuds like when you fight with people
you know what's kind of funny but Mac do
not listen or reach it from people who
don't man I burnt that Lambert
but I'm good I'm good
Jackie oh it's okay it's my Jackie Chan
depression I don't want trouble